uh well thank you general rep uh thank
you for all of your your comments so far
my first question is
uh over your career how have you seen uh
the
division of supply chain management
particularly the how
education is
is provided for supply chain leaders
within the us military yeah so again i
um i'm not a professional logistician
i'm an engineer so i have seen it from
afar
we have
logistics specialties we have officers
who are trained in
transportation uh trained in logistics
trained in uh ordinance which is the the
stuff uh and then quartermaster which
are all the little supplies that have to
come they come together all of those
specialties
at about the 14 15 16 years of service
into what we call a multi-functional
logistician so the
logisticians
are specialties transporters or
um
or supply guys and they they all come
together uh
uh when they get to about the 16-year
mark of their service
because
there you can't have one without the
other
at that higher
level the the guys who have to
coordinate
the supply chains have to understand how
transportation uh links with suppliers
of commodities
and such and so
what was really uh tremendous in
afghanistan was you had the defense
logistics agency which is a global
organization uh that can provide
uh commodities of about any type
linking up with u.s transportation
command which has both c and airlift
nodes in order to to provide all of the
supplies that we needed and then army
materiel command which was really
providing the technical
things the equipment that was necessary
so when i look at supply chain
management i saw it from a user's point
of view
and in my job where i had to start
bringing the afghanistan theater
down
i got to know all of all three of those
communities
and was just deeply impressed by it but
we in the army train
folks in specialties and then bring them
together to bring the the whole package
together after about 15 years
of service in their specialty uh general
okay my question will be uh basically in
private sector and military as well
there are i mean supply chain is
actually something very important so we
always talk about service level we talk
about costs we talk about optimization
but is there any formal platform where
the private sector and military can do
some knowledge sharing or maybe learning
best practice for each other
so
lean six sigma
we took from the from the
private sector
when you when you're trying to optimize
routine uh and reoccurring functions
throughout the supply chain
army materiel command really and
transportation command looked at
how do you optimized for efficiency the
army is not
readily built on efficiency
we will always take effectiveness over
efficiency which tends to mean too much
of commodities because you never want to
get caught without something that you
need but what we have seen is
we can do that a lot smarter
and we got those ideas
from the private sector the private
sector
also has learned from us about uh how to
create
supply chains through
um many different countries that
normally would not have um you know
supported us you know the i would think
that the the us activities in
afghanistan opened up the uzbekistan
tajikistan turkmenistan kazakhstan
kazakhstan to
you know other companies that would not
have normally been
working with those because of the routes
that
dla and transportation command set up
through those i think there's a great
deal that we can learn
from each other i think one of the big
things that corporate america is looking
at is how we do leader development
and the amount of effort that we put
into education
and part of the whole leader development
model throughout the whole range from
when somebody just entered
to when they're a four-star general
general very nice to meet you i'm from
mexico
from the juicy love program
um
i want to ask you
well one thing military logistics is
very common first to thinking of to move
drops and equipment
to a mission a downstream supply
but it's important to the
reverse logistics so
what have been the biggest challenge to
bringing the trust material and
equipment back home to us
for example in retrograde mission
afghanistan yeah so as i talked about
in the talk we just had the biggest
challenge was that afghanistan had only
been an inbound theater nothing really
left so we had almost nine years of
bringing things to afghanistan but never
anything coming back
so there was a mindset of
you had this motor pool
that a company say needed 12 vehicles
but there were 36 vehicles in the motor
pool because you had the original set
that the first unit brought over and
they used for a couple of years and then
they brought in the second set
and so for another couple years they
used that set but they never got rid of
the first set
and then they're using the third or even
fourth set of vehicles
so you had just a tremendous number of
vehicles because nothing ever left so
the biggest challenge was getting back
to those original vehicles and asking
the material managers do you want them
back in the united states
if the answer is no then
have do you have an agreement to give
them or sell them to a foreign country
uh
no do we want us to give them to the
afghans or sell them to the afghans no
then i'm asking permission to destroy
them in place because the last thing we
want to do is spend all that money
hundred and twenty thousand dollars to
fly a piece of equipment all the way
back to the united states from
afghanistan why would we spend 120 000
to fly it back to say jacksonville
uh and take it to a junkyard and have it
junked uh you know and get a couple
thousand dollars for the scrap metal um
you wouldn't so it's forcing
the enterprise to make decisions about
what is there and once they've made
decisions
to have the ability to
uh to give it to you know foreign
countries that's a state department
function
give it to the afghans
destroy it or get it back to united
states so
once we got the decisions
made then it became a logistics exercise
of of destroying a lot of things putting
them on aircraft getting back but it
the creation of multimodal routes if you
can't use pakistan to get it back out
don't fly it all the way back to the
states fly it to the nearest friendly
port
dump it off bring a ship there put it on
because a ship
much more efficient than aircraft is for
moving large pieces of equipment so that
was the challenge is it was really a
mindset
everything came in nothing left now we
had to turn it around so we get that
stuff back out while still fighting a
war
hello general firstly i would like to
express my admiration to your profession
and my question is after the global
crisis in 2008 the public budgets have
been shrinked so how these changes have
affected the supply chain in the army
so the
um
is a great uh
a great
point our budgets under
the budget control act of the summer of
2012 took one trillion dollars out of
the
the defense department budget
uh over a 10-year period so that caused
a great deal of downward pressure on
everything that we did
so it wasn't just supply chain
management now it became decisions what
type of units
if the army has to shrink from 570 000
down to 450 000
which units do you get rid of
when the when it doesn't look like the
world has become any less peaceful
you want to be really careful about
getting rid of your combat units so then
what happens is there's a lot of
pressure on logistics units and they say
well we'll contract out
for that logistics function we can get
rid of that logistics unit because we
don't have the money to pay for those
people
the problem when you contract out for
logistics is
if you have to go someplace like liberia
in ebola and you know a contractor says
i'm not going there um you know that's
where army soldiers and logisticians so
we've had to be very
careful uh as we bring down not to
emasculate to destroy the logistics
capabilities of the unit at the same
time
we were in a
an environment a fiscal environment
where you're fighting two wars where you
almost wanted for nothing
hey we need a new vehicle
you know they spend billions of dollars
to develop the mrap and rapidly get them
over to theater
when the money starts coming down now
hard choices have to be made what's good
enough um we can't afford to just you
know uh throw money at problems because
it doesn't exist anymore so supply chain
management had to become much more
discriminatory rather than just
you know
large pushes of all kinds of things and
you might need 30 percent of what rise
there the rest rots or goes bad it has
to become much more discriminatory
in that regard and that's why i talked
about demand signals
that come from the user here's what we
really need
translated into logistics terms
thank you you bet
thank you my second question is
does the us military have any challenges
in attracting and maintaining
supply chain talent and how does the the
u.s army war college play a role in
addressing those challenges yeah so the
army has not had recruiting challenges
to now we have some challenges in
ensuring that we have the right
diversity in our officer corps
and so we actively try to recruit
um
for diversity because we want the army
to look like america
and so that's important
in our logistics field
it is still a very
popular place to go one of the
challenges in logistics is the people
who
rise to the four-star level in our army
tend to be the fighters not the
logisticians so you get a lot of people
who want to go into logistics but their
idea of a career is 10 years
get a lot of good experience and by the
time
a logistician has finished his eighth
year
in the army he has he or she has already
commanded a company of about 160 to 200
people in complete charge of a logistics
element of about 200 people at 8 years
of service out in the private sector you
rarely get that number of
subordinates until you're 20 or 30 years
so they're very valuable so for some of
our logisticians who think i can't make
it to four star so at about the 10-year
mark
this is a good time to go into corporate
america i've got all of this experience
and training
so we don't have a lot of trouble
recruiting we do have to always be
concerned about retention because we
need those senior members about the
15-year mark where they come together as
those
multi-purpose logisticians uh the supply
chain managers if you will rather than
individual commodity or technical
specialties
we've got to get enough of the good ones
there so the war college
we train strategic leadership
we get those senior logisticians along
with the other branches
and we get them ready to think of
themselves as strategic leaders and
strategic leaders
uh have to be the ones who connect what
you want to achieve your ends or your
objectives with what you have available
your means and through what ways in
order to achieve that you know the
available means through using them in a
certain way to achieve certain ends and
then how much risk are you willing to
accept we've got to get people to think
that way as strategic leaders so
retention
mid-years for logisticians is something
that we have to be concerned with
because they are valuable uh outside the
army
okay um okay my second question will be
uh logistics is actually something i
would say relatively new compared to
other business practices and then in the
corporate world uh they are doing a lot
of things on to improve the system so
for the u.s military point of view what
are the key improvement areas in terms
of logistic practices for the coming
five to ten years i would say yeah i i
would say
your premise that uh logistics is
relatively new
um logistics has always been there the
big challenge is when we started having
centralized supply of armies rather than
um forging supply of armies which was
the napoleonic era
and so
that started for the u.s military in
about the 1860s the civil war the
centralized
logistics
but big changes in terms of
discrimination of logistics as opposed
to just
pushing everything that's needed having
vehicles that can self-diagnose uh
instead of pushing an entire van of
every part that could break on a vehicle
only push forward the parts that are
actually broken or about to break on the
vehicles
that reduces your logistics footprint
allows you the same aircraft to come in
with much more mission critical things
as opposed to one big van with every
part that could be used um
3d printing
may change logistics tremendously i
don't know what that looks like i think
we're very good in plastics and polymers
i'm not sure
um you know if you can fabricate repair
parts you certainly can't do that in the
in the kind of military-grade materials
that we need right now but 5-10 years
from now i mean that could be amazing
you don't actually
push parts forward you push a big
machine forward with with raw materials
and you fabricate the parts
in place
i don't know what that that's going to
lead to but it's certainly going to be
revolutionary in your opinion what has
been the most important military
logistics
and supply chain innovation or
technology
the in recent years
which has a low efficient logistics and
operations and military operation last
um afghanistan and why
yeah
i wish now i was a professional
logistician and i could tell you the
um it gets to this idea of
um knowing what you need and not just
sending everything that you could
possibly need
that requires a diagnostic capability
at the forward part what do we need
it requires the ability of the
warehousing back in the states to be
able to rapidly get the things that are
needed
and then the transportation
infrastructure to to get it there
quickly the
the data links
through the logistics field
you know they rival the operational
links you know we always talk about we
need all this satellite bandwidth in
order to do intelligence and operations
a tremendous amount of satellite
bandwidth is needed for the logistics
to be able to correctly identify what is
needed and when is it needed
so we're not bringing the whole mountain
to afghanistan we're only bringing the
parts of the mountain that are actually
needed
there
that is uh it's a different way of
thinking about things um you know 10
years ago we'll look at the first gulf
war i was i was in the first gulf war we
we got there to saudi arabia we waited
for four months until we built this huge
logistics mountain
behind us and we said okay i think we
got enough stuff
let's go um
no one's gonna give us you know four or
five months to build that that logistic
mountain and we don't need to a lot of
there's a lot of waste
in doing that and so
the ability to discriminate uh and what
is needed and that i think private
sector because
efficiency is important the profit
margins and everything else they can't
just be thinking of effectiveness
that it is
we're learning from the private sector
on how to do that
it is
pretty exciting
and my hat's off to the professional
logisticians because i've always just
been on the hey i need fuel and
uh and i'm in the middle of afghanistan
i need 300 000 gallons per day figure
out how to get it here and they would do
it and i was i was just like wow
that's impressive finally i would like
to ask
about the flexibility of the united
states army in terms of inventory
i think that it's difficult to predict
the magnitude of a of a conflict so i
would like to know if do you have
contracts with suppliers that could
assure the immediate
supply yeah
again you're you're out of my lane of
expertise the defense logistics agency
always maintains a large portfolio of
suppliers
um
and
uh with flexible contracts to uh
uh to be able to you know whether
they're id iqs uh indefinite uh delivery
and definite quantity um
uh kind of contracts we don't know how
much of this we're gonna need but you
know be prepared up to this
so defense logistics agency uh runs that
uh the transportation command uh has
contracts with carriers uh whether it is
civilian uh some
rented 747s or c-lift
carriers so that when
commodities are needed the contracts are
in place
both from a commodity plus the delivery
mechanism to get them
where they need to go
it it allows for this this sense of
logistics discriminate discrimination um
so you're not just pushing everything
forward
i wish i was
i stand in awe of the logistics
community
but
the
their ability to to get just about
anything the challenges that we're
having right now is acquisition
acquisition of something new uh takes a
long time and it's very expensive i mean
we're seeing it with some of the big
weapons programs you know the f-35 for
the u.s air force or a big ship for the
navy
how can we more rapidly uh acquire
things because as you know technology
changes so fast by the time we go
through the six-year program to develop
something and you know get it vetted
through everybody in all these gates by
the time it comes out it's almost
obsolete
based on some you know innovations that
have happened uh in that mean time so
how can we do acquisition reform um
all plays together with
with supply chain management in order to
get the right things um you know for our
soldiers and our airmen and our sailors
wherever they happen to be
so
it was great hearing all of your
experiences in afghanistan and all the
lessons that you learned there how does
the us military capture and and share
those supply chain lessons for future
uh efforts so
you know one of the things the united
states army learned in the 1990s is to
ruthlessly do what we call after action
reviews so every time something happens
we sit down and we talk about what
happened how could it have gone better
what are the lessons that we've learned
we've created a whole organization at
fort leavenworth kansas called the
center for army lessons learned
that
captures all of those lessons so you
don't have to relearn them
in the next time our logistics schools
do the same thing you know how did we do
this what lessons did we learn from it
how do we get that back into what we're
teaching in the schools so that what
we're teaching
is informed by the lessons that we're
learning in places like afghanistan or
djibouti or
wherever
our troops happen to be
and
i think that that's one thing that uh
private organizations can learn from us
is this ruthless
um
critical reviews of of what we did and
how we learn from it and change
what you're teaching at the youngest
levels in order to uh
you know to make sure that you're not
relearning those lessons again
well guys i want to thank you for uh for
taking the time um this is fabulous i
apologize for uh for not being able to
technically answer a lot of the
logistics questions um
uh supply chain chain management uh is
rarely the end-all be-all but it is the
absolute key facilitator of success in
whatever you know business or military
operation so
my hat's off to you i know it's a tough
program and
the school teacher in me says continue
to study hard
because that
is important to uh to do well and
and take what you've learned here back
to
to corporations thank you thank you have
a great day